étudions les chiffres avec vous à lille
à eddy seigneur du décryptage les
guerres et les crises ne sont jamais
bonnes pour le commerce international
l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
vient confirmer évidemment cette règle
on en parle avec vous ali vous nous
dites que l'invasion russe est une crise
supplémentaire qui freine les échanges
internationaux aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment une série de crises qui sont
qui font très très mal au commerce
international regardez sa part en 2008
la crise financière après on enchaîne
par les années trump avec les guerres
commerciales entre les etats-unis et la
chine la pandémie donc il ya vraiment là
pour le coup fermer le commerce mondial
pendant les confinements internationaux
et maintenant la guerre en ukraine qui
vient aussi la frappe est très fortement
un certain nombre de chaînes
d'approvisionnement
on a déjà un impact fort sur le
transport international
c'est très clair l'espace aérien russe
est interdit à près de 36 pays donc
obligation pour le fret aérien
d'emprunter d'autres lignes qui sont
forcément beaucoup plus longue le le
ferroviaire entre l'asie et l'europe à
se porte pas si bien que ça puisque
évidemment ça passe par les nouvelles
routes de la soie entre autres et donc
c'est un petit peu compliqué et le
maritime balle maritime il est super
surchargé donc ce difficile de combler
l'absence du fret aérien pour pouvoir
faire face aux échanges internationaux
d'où le retour le retour du vieux
réflexes protectionnistes et en
particulier dans le secteur agricole
ouais alors j'ai pris des les chiffres
de publier par deux instituts le global
trade alert et puis global sovereign
aviso rixson deux cabinets sa porte
uniquement sur les céréales les céréales
regarder en rouge c'est sous le nom de
mesures protectionnistes de 2009 à 2021
et en bleu ce sont le nombre de mesures
libérales toujours là dans la même année
on peut voir très clairement en ce qui
concerne les céréales le pic en 2014 la
crimée et on voit également remonté en
effet des mesures protectionnistes à
partir du conflit en ukraine alors c'est
quoi essentiellement mesures
protectionnistes c'est évidemment des
aides des subventions publiques un
certain nombre d'entreprises sont des
taxes à l'importation et ce qui est un
petit peu nouveau par rapport à 2014
qu'on voit émerger ce sont carrément des
suspensions voire des interdictions
d'exporter on le voit auprès du burkina
faso la serbie l'egypte la turquie
interdit de d'exporter un certain nombre
de denrées alimentaires et puis autre
technique protectionnistes les licences
obligatoires pour exporter et là on le
voit encore en hongrie en côte d'ivoire
et c est ce qu on se dirige vers un
retour d'une certaine bipolarité
franchement la question est parfaitement
légitime et cette bipolarité opposerait
une économie occidentale à face à une
économie orientales jean occident on
comprend parfaitement que ce serait en
gros le japon l'europe et l'amérique du
nord et lorient se serait évidemment cet
axe moscou pékin alors ça veut pas dire
que c'est la fin de la mondialisation en
revanche c'est sans doute le début des
de la limite d'une certaine
mondialisation et on va assister en
effet un des rapatriements d' usine à
des relocalisations industrielles et une
réflexion sur des chaînes
d'approvisionnement qui soit peut-être
en ce qui concerne europe - diriger vers
l'asie merci beaucoup elle est là dit